こんにちははじめしゃちょーでやってまいりました後半に仕掛けるドッキリシリーズ
良い
バレてますねまず日に仕掛けるシリーズアーも大抵されています私もバレていると思っ
ています視聴者さんの皆さんもバレてると思っていますで正木自身もばレベルと思って
います
ドッキリではありませんもうなんかね by フィってもうなんかどう着るという名の
エンターテイメントみたいになっててそれじゃあ誰なんですよどっ系って言うのはね
結構知らないから起きるっていう面白さか特急だと思ってばテクニカルの方法で正木を
取ってるね仕掛けてくると思います今回見つけたのはこちら
どこから見つけてくるんだろう俺これ練習で流れて掘ってきてでございます
ホッチキスで全力風ホッチキスで全力
う
ホッチキスで全粒が流れる系は今まで見たことないでこれもニュータイプってことです
さすがにほっ次何流れるとは思わないってはあーこわいこわいこわい
ぱっと目安全にホッチキスんですねよくできてるな
完全にほっちってホッチキスじゃねえよおそらくギミックとしてはここですねポケット
の部分を握ってバー新てると電流が流れるという視点でございます
僕は仕掛けるがある
正規ねーなーとしてこれの電流の強さを知っておかなければいけません
ああもうこれ本当に選んだびっくりではなきゃいけないんですよ開けますよ
はここはこっちギスとやや握る感じですごいやだけます行けます出来ませんはできます
よ
あっへろっでなくなる
うううううう4キャリパー恋
本当にやだこと言えば国名がこんな値段で食べればいやだいやだ
います今じゃフィギュアた2つさんパパ
car
ああっ乗って乙津ちゃったって凝っちゃったか壊れてないかも行って確かめなきゃ
強いず当然やばいやばい
伊予いいのきたよそういうわけで今回はですねちょっと僕ひとりで恋の仕掛けるとも
完全にばれちゃうので考えれ
なんとプーさん前に来ていただきましたどうなーん
tes
もうた分の1死区切ってまま時にばれちゃうんで初心の社員さんとお口でご座薬資料
ぐっさんこのちょっと急がせて資料作ってるからそれほっついて止める手伝いをして
くれる
ちょっと触ってみてくださいよ餌にするだけっこりゃー
頭痛のマジでその4
えっマッハ
4要望結構笑え2分宮状態タイプで結構胸膜場所で今回もう
社員さんの目標は別の
ほっ次撮影しましたあ
ブーバパティの社員さんを使ってる
この2つが整ったとき多分ポジ信じきっていくと思うんですよ違っ行ってみよう
なんかなんで発火しかって言われるとまあ
ブームのまだ小さいクリエイターさん大変なクリーム屋さんとかでも呼べとか何か好き
なことを書かせて桜はなるほどゲーテ b というか想像力を膨らませて食べますし
この
拍手の3倍の資料が必要だから
例えば始めた手が離せないみたいなんで今
でますんで立ち香ちっこいな
これちょっとルームでねべ部分で酒いただけるかですね
神ですね
まとめたんだよね
ぶっぱが2人煽ったって話なんですよ
サンマリ
思っておりますこの a 自分でこっち来て持ってるんか
順番予想解析でなぜ23歳男性が俺の家に遊びに来るときにホッチキス持ち込んでいる
んだいや今はそんな事どうでもいい今ならまだ間に合う
を告げたは0ん
4日
ni
実際ままもはや俺どっちの火種を取る操り人形
低迷の命も時間の問題デー
親父政府じゃう
どうぞこれでパチッとパイプ役か参ったです
カンパ様になってるん
ben
ません
ん
大丈夫
これあの軍資料で今度は子どもたちにちょっと通りに家を変えてもらおうっていう説教
住人
使用するなぁ
ヌー c 4せないボールは
さーああ
me
あああああああいいいい
ad
いっ
じゃーんっ
目指しにか分からん何ってかなぁこんな都合よく守った口だけ金が電気通りそうだ
ああ
おかしいなぁバレないと思ったんだよな何十バーン